what about the dog fighting uh what
aspects of that were accurate so dog
fighting is kind of uh an interesting
um conversation because it's not the
most tactically relevant skill set
nowadays uh by traditional standards
because the the ranges with which we
engage and employ weapons are very uh
significant and so if we're in a
scenario we're in a dog fight like that
um a lot of things have probably gone
wrong right and that's kind of how this
mission was set up right it was a you
know a no-win type scenario most likely
um and so for a dogfight the aircraft
size and the ranges and the turn
radiuses make it so it's not very
theatrical right the aircraft look small
and while it's intense with the systems
I have and the sensors and what I'm
feeling and all that if I you know we've
done it and we've done it right we take
video of that and it's just like a blue
sky and you see a little dot out there
so not very interesting and so anytime
it really looks interesting in dogfight
Arena
um that's most likely uh fiction because
we really only get close for you know a
millisecond as we're zipping past each
other at the merge you're breaking my
heart right I know
you can go and have fun but you know in
a dogfight specifically maybe that was
more common in the earlier Awards of
World War II and before that were the is
it due to the sort of the range and the
effectiveness of the weapon systems
involved exactly and the accuracy of the
targeting systems at range but there's
also a train of thought that hasn't
actually been tested out yet which is
with the Advent of
um Advanced electronic warfare ew and or
unmanned assets the battle space may get
so complex and missiles uh May
essentially just get dropped out of the
sky or wasted such that you're going to
be in close with either IR missiles or
guns if it's a no kidding
um you know must defend type scenario